g
le vent les oiseaux
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jour nuit jour nuit jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc maintenant se retrouvent pour
le bilan de un an de pêche donc surtout
moi mais aussi un peu mon frère mon île
à une partie de ces foyers qui sont
restés chez lui donc là on commence par
ce qui est un peu insolite et que j'ai
gardées donc il ya un drame ça c'est les
parties du vélo qu'on a fait dans la
vidéo où le voisin appelle la police on
a jeté le reste du vélo vous verrez
pourquoi en vidéo
[Musique]
ensuite les boules de pétanque qui a
certaines qui sont en parfait état
d'autres totalement brouiller une
épuisette
donc voilà en mode est assez cool aussi
j'ai trouvé en même temps que le
revolver colts navy l'habite en acier
que je garde aussi précieusement au cas
où j'avais ça peut servir
la chaise du pêcheur nickel et le repose
pied trouver un autre endroit toujours
aussi bien
ensuite la il ya un tas de ferraille
donc dans les cartons l'étape suivante
ni énormément de ferraille partout de
toutes tailles que des déchets qui
partiront faire ailleurs
là il ya toute la partie moteur on voit
ici
donc ça s'arrête vaut plus cher chez le
ferrailleur je le vendrais et le gros
tas donc là c'est l'équivalent seulement
de trois modes fait ralentir et j'en ai
déjà vendu pour à peu près une tonne
avec mon frère on le voit dans la vidéo
où on va chez le ferrailleur des plaques
d'égout des pics et les piquets de
péniches j'ai un peu traîné pour pouvoir
le vendre
voilà maintenant on va passer à tout ce
qui est outil et voilà toute une flopée
de taux décidées râteaux des bêches clé
à molette burin un marteau bien sûr de
toute taille surtout pour planter les
piques et deux péniches un pied-de-biche
sûrement pour entrer par effraction ou
casser les voitures et là les petits
outils que j'ai réparé donc tout ça
c'est du péché et du fonctionnel on voit
vraiment qu'il y a de tout tournevis
pinces des clés de toutes tailles même
des outils de plomberie en parfait état
voilà pour les principales trouvailles
enfin ça c'est les moins bien on va dire
maintenant se retrouve à laitages pour
aller
trouvailles les plus intéressantes donc
maintenant on va présenter tous les
leurres qu'on a trouvé donc les leurs de
pêche dans le canal du midi
essentiellement donc on voit qu'ils
avaient lors de toutes tailles
il y en a certains qui sont encore en
très bon état et d'autres qui sont bien
allier où il ya plus là me sens voilà
donc super collection ils ont une
certaine valeur et on revient à certains
qui sont énormes comme celui ci je me
demande ce qu'ils voulaient pêcher dans
le canal avec ça après les leurs on
passe aux objets de voitures donc
cylindres de voitures morceau d'art avec
les pistons bouchon de réservoir à
quelques visuels une clé l'ancien
probablement médiévale en faire plutôt
bien conservée dh qui sont aussi
sûrement très vieille peut-être du 19e
ou xviiie siècle après il ya les canons
de fusils de la guerre comme un passé
mon ami alex
voilà peut être bon bien sûr ils sont
très abîmées mais ça reste bébé est un
fusil de chasse d'armes
donc celui ci est totalement corrodé
mais je pense que je vais pouvoir le
restaurer je vous montrerai ça en vidéo
ensuite une pince multi tout qu'il faut
que je restaure aussi et les couteaux
donc les couteaux il ya celui
estampillés art met un couteau ica gros
couteau de cuisine en parfait état
petit couteau de pêche couteau de pêche
et couteaux de survie donc ça très bien
aussi à cran d'arrêt un vieux couteau et
surtout un énorme la gueule couteau de
chasse donc celui-là je pense qu'il a
servi à faire des bêtises puisqu'il
s'est retrouvé sous un pont le hachoir
pareil assez étonnante trouvé ça dans
l'eau mais très belles pièces que j'ai
pas fini de restaurer reste encore un
peu de noir donc je vous montrerai
sûrement le résultat quand il sera fini
en photo après on passe aux choses plus
sérieuses les balles donc balle de
mousquets de plusieurs calibres la
baïonnette
donc ça c'est une baïonnette à douille
que j'ai trouvé aussi au bord du canal
phase 1 0 deux ports j'ai mis parce que
je pensais que c'était une culasse mais
au final pas du tout c'est juste pas
vers eux un canon trouvé par an aux
frères à colombier donc c'est un talent
de fusil de ball-trap surtout des bons
puisqu'ils se retrouvent à colombier il
a dû servir à quelque chose d'autre
la crosse de ce thème et le chargeur de
semaine ensuite les munitions donc là on
voit qu'il ya des munitions d'à peu près
tous les calibres ça va du tout-petit 22
long rifle 9 mm calibre 12 de la
munition ça je crois que c'est dû
carcano des mother et des mêmes des
énormes munitions donc celle ci en a
besoin d avoir uniquement si on a la
licence de tir où le permis de chasse
pour ce qui est déjà en trouvez donc la
plus petite le vélo dogues
il est bien abîmée mais ça va c'est une
très jolie pièce ici on a deux le
faucheur inquiet plutôt bien conservé
très sympa que j'ai restauré dans une
vidéo et celui ci que bon il n'est pas
restera bien sûr mais ça reste un
revolver le pistolet des résistants donc
su l'avant il est bien là but et c'est
un le français vous l'avez reconnu et
surtout le colt 1851 et vie que j'ai
restauré ont bien sûr ils tirent pas
parce que le canon est bien trop abîmée
mais ça reste une très belle pièce de
collection
ensuite il ya ce fusil d'armes que j'ai
péché mais pas en vidéo suis là je
l'avais fait avant donc voilà à canon
scié qui a dû servir à des braquages au
pareil a pas de numéro de série il est
totalement inutilisable est impossible
de le retracer
c'est pourquoi je les gardais aucune de
ces armes ne peut tirer et aucune ne
peut bien sûr être confronté dans une
affaire car elles n'ont pas de numéro de
série utilisable 6 à celui là présente
ces catégories d donc le numéro de série
n'est pas tracée donc voilà pour les
trouvailles les plus belles donc une vue
d'ensemble
donc il ya ici un an de pêche aliments
voilà pour le récap de sept années 2020
il reste trois trouvailles
donc vous avez réservé un top 3 la plus
intéressante donc la plus intéressante
ça va être le pistolet de cavalerie
trouvait à grenoble par mes soins donc
plus intéressante parce que pour nous ça
reste la plus vieille armes jamais péché
et je pense que c'est aussi la plus
vierge aller pêcher empêcha les membres
dans la catégorie arme à feu oui
normalement on a regardé des tonnes de
vidéos on a posté sur facebook et tous
et personne n'a fait aussi bien une et
sur du 300 ans dans l'eau donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas mal
ensuite numéro 2 je pense que ce sera le
scooter royal et scooters énorme scooter
mbk booster qu'on aurait dû garder
d'ailleurs parce que pas mal de
personnes voulaient nous racheter vous
voulez un petit peu voir ça oui parce
qu'il n'était pas volée c'était vraiment
la finalité c'est mon oeuvre
on a appelé la police qui nous a signalé
on pouvait garder son boulet bon samedi
avec un peu on a fait un tour mais on
aurait pu faire mouche et numéro 1 et
numéro un en termes d'intérêt on va dire
est atterré donc c'est le sait le porte-
menu du quai ouest donc voilà vous avez
sûrement vu la vidéo pour ceux qui nous
suivent
c'est voilà c'était un objet chargé
d'une histoire un petit peu douloureuse
mais retracer l'histoire d'un objet
péché c'est vraiment le rêve de tous les
pêcheurs et je pense qu on a tous les
deux très envie de repêcher quelque
chose avec une histoire aussi un point
derrière les occire a commenté aussi
loin c'est ce qui va nous motiver pour
2020 on a encore beaucoup de projets
voilà je vais pas spoiler mais pas mal
de contenu arrivée sur la chaîne
on a encore une fois beaucoup de
tournages dans ce dont elles gras
mercier voilà merci aussi on a un jeu
concours qui arrive donc voilà je
concours pour lesquelles les lots sont
encore à définir mais il y aura bref il
y aura des éléments
oui il y aura 30 ans un aimant visé mme
arroyo voilà sinon portez vous bien et à
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche
yes
[Musique]